OLIVIA: Welcome to Kitchen Sink.
This is Kitchen Sink
the cafe, and this
is Kitchen Sink the
teaching kitchen,
which I hope you'll come
and visit and learn about.
We have a lot of cooking
classes going on.
But today, it's my pleasure
to have our first guest
from San Francisco, an author,
a food writer, and a chef.
Carolyn Jung was a
former colleague of mine.
She's a food writer,
an award-winning food
writer for the San
Jose Mercury, and she
hit upon this idea of writing a
book about the very best chefs
in San Francisco and getting a
recipe from each one of them.
And she chose for us
today Chef Bill Corbett
of Absinth, which is a noted
San Francisco restaurant.
And he's got some treats
for us to taste afterwards.
CAROLYN JUNG: Thank you,
guys, for taking time out
on your very, very busy day.
I know you have
work to do, but this
is so much better, isn't it?
I mean, we have an afternoon
of talking about sweets
and then eating dessert.
So I think that
beats work any day.
So as Olivia was so kindly
enough to introduce me,
I'm a long-time Bay
Area food writer.
I was at the Mercury
News for many years,
and now I freelance for a
number of publications locally,
nationally, even
sometimes internationally.
And I do my own blog
called foodgal.com,
and I was lucky enough to
be approached last year
to do this book, "San
Francisco Chef's Table,"
which is a compilation
of about 50
or more restaurants
around the Bay
Area with their stories and
their signature recipes.
So it's sort of
fell into my lap I
like to say or
actually into my inbox.
Here I was, just working
away on my computer at home,
and this email came over
from the publisher, who
does this chef series
books around the country,
asking me if I wanted to do
the San Francisco one which,
shocked as I was, there was not
a San Francisco one already,
and I was thrilled.
But then I had a heart
attack when she said,
we can only give you
three months to do it.
Which yeah, if you've ever
worked on a project like that,
is not a whole lot of time.
So I was really
grateful that I was
able to sweet-talk
a number of chefs,
including the one
sitting next to me,
into being a part of this book.
Because really, they are the
ones that made this such,
I think, a really remarkable,
usable, and fun book.
And what I looked
for in the chefs
that I chose was restaurants
that represented San Francisco,
either they were iconic
ones like Swan Oyster Depot,
or hot, hip, happening
restaurants of the moment
like State Bird Provisions in
San Francisco that most of us
can't even get into,
even if we wish we could.
And recipes that
were actually doable,
because I don't want
the book to just
be sitting pretty
on a coffee table.
I want people to actually
try and cook from it.
And granted, there are
some dishes in there
that are more
challenging than others.
There are others that are
very, very straightforward.
So I would like to
introduce you to a pastry
chef who I so admire.
And if you have not had the
chance to try his desserts,
you will this afternoon,
and I guarantee
that it will put a
smile on your face.
So Bill Corbett is the executive
pastry chef of the Absinthe
Group in San Francisco, which
consists of Absinthe Brasserie,
the Boxing Room, Comstock
Saloon, Harlequin,
and a soon-to-be-named
new restaurant in Soma.
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, it's
a soon-to-be-named Spanish
restaurant in Soma.
CAROLYN JUNG: And you are
responsible for the dessert
programs at all of
those restaurants.
BILL CORBETT: Yeah,
that's correct.
I do desserts for all
four of the restaurants
we have currently, and soon I'll
have a fifth one on my hands.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
you're a busy man.
BILL CORBETT: We're pretty busy.
We have it pretty organized, so
it doesn't each my whole life
up, but it works out OK.
CAROLYN JUNG: So one thing
you might not know about Bill
is that, if given his druthers,
he would have actually not been
a pastry chef but a heavy
metal musician, right?
BILL CORBETT: Just rock
and role in general, yeah.
If I could play guitar
and that well, then maybe.
But definitely music is
a big passion of mine.
But cooking is a little
more realistic, I think.
CAROLYN JUNG: So I
had the pleasure also
of interviewing one of
your colleagues and friends
recently, Brooks
Headley, the pastry chef
of Del Posto in New
York, and he used
to be a heavy metal drummer.
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, he's
the real-deal drummer.
I actually listened to his bands
long before I ever met him.
And so he's been in a lot
of really great punk bands
in the '90s.
CAROLYN JUNG: And I
know there-- and I
know they're probably other
few pastry chefs out there
with this fondness for
that type of music,
so I just have to
ask-- on one hand,
you have these very
dark lyrics in music
and on the other hand in
what you do in your day job,
you have this very sweet, frilly
spun-sugar type environment.
So what is up with that?
BILL CORBETT: I don't know if
the environment's so sweet,
if you actually hang
out in the kitchen,
but I think there's a certain
level of precision, maybe, that
goes along with both
sides of things.
When you listen to
heavy metal, there's
a lot of precision in the
drums and the guitars.
So I think there's-- and
with pastry, it's all about--
there's a lot of precision that
goes into everything from how
you weigh the ingredients
to how the dish looks.
And so I think it
might have more
to do with that, that
kind of appreciation.
And punk rock and
heavy metal are
sort of the underdogs
of the music industry,
and we're also the underdogs
of the culinary scene.
We're always the ones
in the background.
So I think it all
works out well.
It makes sense, I think.
CAROLYN JUNG: Do
you listen to metal
while you're cooking and baking?
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, I
torture my cooks a lot.
They have to listen
to-- but they--
it's not like they don't get to
listen to their music, either.
So there's a good
balance in the kitchen.
But definitely I listen to
a lot of more aggressive,
faster music.
I think it keeps me going more.
It keeps me excited, and I
don't get bored that way.
CAROLYN JUNG: So I know
you grew up in Canada.
And yeah.
So you grew up in Canada, and
you left Canada for Florida
with $800 in your
pocket following
some friends who were in bands.
And you took, I guess,
your first job, actually,
in the restaurant industry
at the Psychic Cafe.
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, yeah.
So I worked in-- back in,
I think it was around 99,
I moved to Florida.
I had met all these amazing
people in punk bands,
and they were all touring and
living this inspiring life,
and I thought, this is awesome.
I want to go live
with these people.
So I had about $800 in
my pocket and moved down.
I sold tons of extra records
I didn't want any more,
things like that just
to get some money
and just moved to Florida
with no real plan.
I ended up living
there for two years.
Met my wife now.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
maybe it was fate?
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, I
think it might have been.
And then I ended up
working at a cafe,
working in the kitchen and
kind of running the kitchen.
And you could go in and get
a psychic reading and lunch
kind of thing.
It was really-- it was an
odd place, that's for sure.
CAROLYN JUNG: And how
long were you there?
BILL CORBETT: I was
there pretty much
the whole two years
I lived in Florida.
So it was interesting.
It's an interesting
culture, let's just
say, with all these psychics
running around and then.
Yeah, it's very Florida almost.
CAROLYN JUNG: Did you ever
have a psychic reading done
yourself?
BILL CORBETT: No, I didn't
really, I don't know.
They would always try to
tell me things about my life
and what I should
be doing and things,
and I would always just
take it with a grain of salt
and get back to making a
sandwich or something, whatever
I was doing at the time.
CAROLYN JUNG: So now
it kind of was fate
that you met your wife there,
because you then followed her
to New York, where
she was studying.
And it was in New
York where you met
someone who was very pivotal all
in your career, Lincoln Carson.
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, so after--
CAROLYN JUNG: Who is
the corporate pastry
chef for Michael
Mina restaurants.
BILL CORBETT:
Actually, not anymore.
He just left.
CAROLYN JUNG: Did see?
Where is he now?
BILL CORBETT: He
just moved to LA.
He just helped open a place
called Superba Food and Bread
in LA.
CAROLYN JUNG: OK.
BILL CORBETT: But I ended up
moving New York after my wife
and I got married.
She was going to
art school there
and ended up wanting to
work in real kitchens there
and fell in.
Basically I didn't have
culinary school background,
and I hadn't worked on
the line in New York,
so nobody would hire me.
And then I luckily
met this person
who was working
for Lincoln Carson,
and she said, why
don't you come try out?
So I went and tried out, and
he saw that I wanted to learn,
so he hired me.
And then from then on, he
took me under his wing.
And for my career, it really--
I don't think my career
would have gone where it
has gone without having that
kind of encounter.
CAROLYN JUNG: Because actually,
you started on the savory side,
right?
BILL CORBETT: Sort of.
I started on savory in really
weird places like the Mongolian
Grill Buffet and like,
and then in Psychic Cafe,
and then I was working
at a bar in Brooklyn.
When I first moved to New
York, I worked in the kitchen
at a bar.
And so I did all the
savory food in there,
but-- So sort of
on the savory side,
but nowhere in a real
serious cooking environment
until I got into pastry.
CAROLYN JUNG: So what's
the most important thing
Lincoln taught you?
BILL CORBETT: To be methodic
about things when it comes.
Everything from even zesting
an orange, making sure you're
doing it in a methodical
way so it's more efficient
and time sensitive.
And he taught me
so much, though,
that's just like one
of the major things.
He was a very methodical
worker in the way
he prepares a dish and
the way he executes it.
And so he taught me a ton
about how to execute dishes
from start to finish and how
to produce them at high volume
and be able to still maintain
consistency and quality.
CAROLYN JUNG: And then you
went to go work at wd-50
with Wiley Dufresne, the
madman of molecular gastronomy.
So in an environment like
that, do all the rules go out
the window and anything
is fair game to try?
BILL CORBETT:
There's a definite-
I wouldn't say all the
rules go out the window.
I would say Wiley's a big
believer in a solid foundation
and understanding
your technique.
But then it's like once
you understand the rules,
then you can break the
rules kind of thing.
And that was one of the
most incredible learning
experiences, working with Wiley.
Because I worked under the
pastry chef, Sam Mason,
there at the time,
and then he left
and Alex Stupak came on board.
And just seeing how you
threw everything out
and just you were able to
try anything you wanted.
And Wiley, you could
come to him and say,
what if you did this
with this ingredient?
And he would say, try it.
He wouldn't just try to
give you the answer of it
why it wouldn't work
or why it might.
He would say try it.
CAROLYN JUNG: Can you describe
a couple of the really out there
desserts that you did there?
BILL CORBETT: Some
of the desserts
we were doing
there were-- we did
a manchego cheesecake with
quince and pineapple, which
I think today maybe doesn't
sound as crazy as it did maybe
10 years ago, but
it was kind of-- it
was a bigger technical
trick, I think, then.
And so much, the
flavor was so mind--
it's not something that
maybe blew people's minds,
flavor wise.
When you ate it,
it was really good.
But what I'm saying,
like the thought process
or when you see that on a
menu, you don't go oh, my god,
manchego in a dessert.
But it was more the
technique of how
do you get manchego into a
cheesecake sort of thing.
Because if you just throw
manchego in a cheesecake,
it's very hard cheese.
It doesn't really break down.
When it melts, it
gets kind of oily.
And sometimes it was
just trying to figure out
the almost dumbest
way of going about it.
So we ended up just pureeing
the cheese with water
and making this
thick puree that was
kind of the consistency
of cream cheese
and then folding it into
the cake, and it worked.
But so there'd be
desserts like that.
I try-- they don't-- I guess
now it was weird because they
don't seem like they
sound so outrageous,
but we were doing things, I
guess, at the time that were.
We were doing things
with a butternut squash
sorbet with chocolate.
And Sam Mason was doing things
like soy caramel and parsnip
cake.
And really-- but exercising
a really great balance
between sweet and savory.
The dish, it was
still a dessert.
It I wasn't a savory dish
with some sugar added to it.
It was still a
dessert, and I think
that was the important thing.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
then, of course,
you went on to work at Qua
in San Francisco, Daniel
Patterson's famed restaurant.
Now, Daniel, I know, is known to
be quite the taskmaster, quite
the perfectionist.
So what was it like
working for him?
BILL CORBETT: It was great,
because it really taught
me to boil down
the things I knew
and strip away the
nonessential things,
like the things that
were maybe fluff
and didn't really need
to be in the dish.
It's taking a dish and boiling
it down to it's essentials.
It was-- the dishes--
yeah, there's
this whole perfectionist
thing going around,
but there's also just
incredible ingredients
and using the best ingredients,
and that was what it was about.
And then having the food
not interfere with itself.
But still, I don't know, the
combination seemed so simple
at the time, and my
dishes got simpler
and simpler and simpler,
almost, the way they looked.
But the technique behind
them was still the same.
I was just stripping
away a lot, I think.
CAROLYN JUNG: I think that's
true with a lot of chefs
as they mature.
Can you just tell by
looking at a plate
if there's like everything
plus the kitchen sink on there
that it's a younger chef
who probably made it?
BILL CORBETT: Yeah,
I think there's
a lot of times you can look
and say OK, this person
has a lot of ideas,
and they're trying
to fit all these
ideas into one plate.
And it's not a horrible thing.
It's part of the
learning process.
But you start to, as
you grow and mature,
you definitely learn what's
necessary, what's not,
and how you can
actually just make
the dish greater by almost
simplifying a little bit.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
where does inspiration
come from when you set about
creating a new dessert?
Is it an ingredient
that you spy?
Is it something
from your memory?
What triggers it?
BILL CORBETT: It's just
everything that surrounds me,
almost.
It's not like I'm inspired by
everything in some hippie way
like oh, look at the
leaves out there.
Now I'm going to make a desert
based on that bush over there.
But it's more like, for
me, it's just inspiration
comes either from at the market.
I see some really great
product, and you just
can't turn away from it.
Like meiwa kumquats,
are an example.
From Brokaw Farms at the San
Francisco ferry building.
You get these kumquats, and
you just eat them whole.
They're not bitter.
They're sweet.
They're really well
balanced Just enough acid
and you're just like I can't
not use this ingredient.
And so you build
a dish around it.
And then sometimes
it is a combination.
Sometimes it's, like the
beet cake in the book,
it's my take on the salad you
find at every San Francisco
restaurant, which is
roasted beets, goat
cheese, and walnuts.
And then maybe it's got some
orange segments or something
or some fennel involved,
but generally there's
three ingredients.
So I thought they
all work in desserts,
so why don't I make
a dessert with them?
So I did the beet cake with
a goat fromage blanc frosting
and then candied walnuts.
So it'll be like that.
I'll see something,
and I'll want to riff
on it a little bit.
Or it's just this great
combination of herbs and fruit,
like strawberries go
so well with things
like tarragon or
basil or fennel.
There's so many
different things.
And I pull lot of that from
the savory side, I think.
CAROLYN JUNG: And when
you start experimenting,
how long does it take
to perfect something?
Is it many, many, many
tries, or sometimes
is it just bang on
right from the start?
BILL CORBETT: It's
pretty rare that it's
bang on right from the start.
When that happens, it's
amazing, but it's pretty rare.
I would say it's
usually-- at this point,
I feel like I have a better
understanding than I've ever
had in the past, where I
can put together a dish
and be close on the first try.
But then it usually
takes two to three
tries before I tweak
out what I need
or what I think the dish needs.
So yeah, it's never
usually the first try.
It usually takes a little while.
CAROLYN JUNG: And is there any
ingredient that you could never
envision in a dessert,
or is everything
pretty much up for
grabs in your mind?
BILL CORBETT: I think
just, like, onions.
CAROLYN JUNG: Onions?
OK.
BILL CORBETT: Onions and
garlic for the life for me.
CAROLYN JUNG: Garlic ice cream?
No?
BILL CORBETT: I know some
people have done things
with black garlic, and maybe.
But I don't know.
I just can't see it.
But there are other
ingredients maybe
I would have thought
the same thing.
I had a dish from Brooks
Headley, speaking of him.
Probably about
two years ago now,
for a year and a half ago, where
it was [? acento ?] carpaccio
and yeast ice cream and
just really nice olive oil.
So it was raw sunchokes
and yeast ice cream.
And I thought, OK,
this is out there.
This is not going to work.
And then I ate it,
and it was amazing.
And he said it was
his version of dipping
your fries in your milkshake.
And so but it was one of
the biggest surprises.
And when I get those
surprises, those
are what really
excite me and make
me want to explore further
and maybe past what I'm
comfortable with or
what I think is--
it makes you think maybe
this, maybe I'm totally wrong.
Maybe the ideas
that I have formed,
I need to throw them out
the window and start again.
CAROLYN JUNG: So I know we've
talked about this because I've
written about this for
Food Arts magazine,
but I know there are times
where you come up with a dessert
and you think,
oh, this is a hit.
And you wait and you wait, and
nobody, or very few people,
order it in the dining room.
Has that happened
rarely, often, sometimes?
BILL CORBETT: It
happens once in a while.
I always think I
can predict a hit,
and I feel like
I'm always wrong.
Every time I think I've
got a hit on my hands,
I'm almost always--
I might enjoy
the dessert, the staff
might enjoy the dessert,
and the guest who orders it
probably enjoys the dessert.
But it's getting
the guests to order
the dessert is the
trick sometimes.
But there's been
really obvious ones,
like I think the one
Food Art's referring
to was a peanut [INAUDIBLE]
with Concord grape jelly.
And I was like oh, it's
peanut butter and jelly.
What can go wrong?
And no one ordered it.
And then I don't know if
maybe peanut butter is maybe
too low brow for people
to pay $10 for a dessert
with peanut butter.
I don't know.
But like I think that
might be just it.
Sometimes you think you've got
it, and you totally do not.
You think oh, I'm just
going to slam-dunk this one,
knock it out, and
no one orders it.
But then you do
another dish sometimes
that people really surprise you.
I did a parsnip dish.
It was actually the parsnip
cake that Sam Mason taught me.
I served it with it was
just a buttermilk ice cream.
It was really simple, and
it was a parsnip milk jam.
And I thought no
one's going to order
this parsnips for dessert.
I'll put it on the
menu because it'll
be fun for a little
while, but I'm probably
going to take it off
in a week or two.
And it ended up being a big
hit, and people loved it.
Or the beet cake, for instance.
I thought the beet
cake, I'll put it on.
We'll sell a few.
It's not going to be crazy,
but it was a big hit,
and we actually ended
up making, I think,
almost a wedding cake a month.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh,
really, wedding cake?
Wow.
BILL CORBETT: Beet
cake for wedding cakes.
It kind of--
CAROLYN JUNG: Kind of a new
thing instead of red velvet?
BILL CORBETT: Kind of, yeah.
I think, sometimes I think
just go with your gut
and what you're excited about.
Then you're kind of
cooking from this place
that you're actually excited.
And it's almost like it
always comes out better.
CAROLYN JUNG: Now, you would
think a pastry chef is someone
who goes out, orders
dessert all the time,
but that's not you, right?
BILL CORBETT: No.
The only time I
think I order dessert
is when I either know
who be pastry chef is
and I know they have an
actual pastry chef in house.
Then I'll probably
order dessert.
But if I'm going to most, your
neighborhood restaurant that
doesn't necessarily
pay for a pastry chef
and doesn't have a
pastry chef, I'll
take an extra potato
course or something.
I'm like I'd rather
have-- I crave salt.
I eat sweet all day long,
I'm tasting it all day long,
and I crave salt at
the end of the day.
And I'd rather-- I find,
like, cheese and potatoes
and all these horrible
things that I shouldn't
be eating way more satisfying
at the end of the day, probably.
CAROLYN JUNG: And you did not
grow up in a foodie family.
BILL CORBETT: No, not at all.
No.
CAROLYN JUNG: What did
you eat as a child?
BILL CORBETT: You don't want to.
It's like my parents
are going to call me
up and yell at me, but--
CAROLYN JUNG: They don't
watch YouTube, right?
BILL CORBETT: No, my
dad, I had to set him up
with a Gmail account, and it
didn't really work so well.
I don't think he's ever used it.
I had to literally
set it up for him
and then call him on
the phone and guide them
through the logging
in so I could send him
a video to watch.
And then so yeah, I don't--
and then he was like
where's the volume?
Where's the volume?
I can't hear anything.
So he's not going to see it.
My mom might see it.
But yeah, it was-- my
parents weren't, and I'm not
talking trash, but they
just weren't good cooks.
And they never-- there
were a few things
here and there that
they surprise you.
You pull out the recipe cards
from the old Betty Crocker
recipe card box,
and you get excited.
But there's a lot of things.
I can remember my grandfather
babysitting us once,
and my grandfather was
even way further removed
from cooking
process of any kind.
He tried to serve me a
bouillon cube in hot water
and call it soup or something.
I was like, this isn't soup.
Just open a can.
But yeah, so yeah, I
definitely didn't grow up
in a foodie family.
My dad still jokes
about it a lot.
He's always asking
me why I've got
to buy these fancy ingredients
and things like that.
CAROLYN JUNG: I remember
when I interviewed you
for my own blog years ago.
You said your parents
had never eaten
in a restaurant
you'd worked act.
Is that still true?
BILL CORBETT: It's
still true, yeah,
because they live in Canada,
and when they come to visit,
I usually take time off.
And they actually--
so it's usually
a thing where we
don't get the chance
to actually come sit down.
And they haven't
actually been out here
since I've lived out here.
I've been home a couple times,
but they haven't been out here.
So they haven't
had the chance, no.
They came to New York once,
and we went to the restaurants
so I could show
them where I worked.
It was a day we were closed.
And so yeah, so they actually
haven't been able to-- they
haven't been to eat at
one of the restaurants
that I cook in yet.
CAROLYN JUNG: I think
you need to remedy that.
BILL CORBETT: Yeah,
we'll work on that.
CAROLYN JUNG: So given
your love for music,
if you wrote a heavy metal song
about your life and career,
what title would you give it.
BILL CORBETT: I don't know.
I don't know.
Probably have something to do
with getting my act together.
CAROLYN JUNG: I think
you've done pretty well.
I think you need
another title there.
So you're now also one of the
founding members of Killed
by Dessert, an annual
event to benefit Share
our Strength, which it
started in New York,
but now it's in San Francisco.
Why did you want to
become involved with that?
And tell people a little
bit about that event.
BILL CORBETT: So
Killed by Dessert
is an event where me and
five other pastry chefs,
we basically created
this event where you come
and you pretty much eat dessert.
We do each--
CAROLYN JUNG: Not bad, huh?
BILL CORBETT: We each
do a savory course.
So you come in, you get
a savory hors d'oeuvre,
and then you sit down, and
you get 12 courses of dessert.
You get two courses
from each pastry chef.
So it's kind of like a fine
dining menu in reverse, almost.
But the pastry chefs we have
involved are incredible.
There's Lincoln Carson,
who I used to work for,
and then Christina
Tosi from Momofuku,
Brooks Headley from Del
Posto, Michael Laiskonis., who
used to be the former
pastry chef at La Bernadin,
Francisco Migoya, who
works for the CIA.
So yeah, we have--
there's six of us,
and it's this incredible
thing, and basically
what happens-- The reason
it all came about was just
we wanted to do a
pastry event together.
And then we picked a charity
because we didn't really
care about-- we weren't doing
it to raise money for ourselves,
so we thought let's give the
money to Share our Strength.
And then it worked
out because then they
could use the-- we could use
their ticketing infrastructure
and things like that.
So they supported us
that way, and then
they get to keep all
the money, and it
makes our lives much
easier because we
don't have to worry about
selling tickets and all
that kind of thing.
CAROLYN JUNG: And is it
happening again this year?
BILL CORBETT: It'll happen.
It's probably going
to happen in LA.
It hasn't been announced yet.
We're trying to
figure it out still,
but it happens in a
different city every time.
So we did one in Brooklyn.
We did one in Austin.
We sort of did a half
one in Washington, DC,
and we did San
Francisco last year.
This year it'll probably be LA.
There's a couple other
cities on the map
that we keep making promises
to, but it's an amazing event.
You know, we raised, last
year in San Francisco
we raised $20,000 for
Share our Strength.
CAROLYN JUNG: So I know
you don't like the word
self-taught, but you did
not go to cooking school,
and you learned by
doing through working
with really incredible people.
So for anyone out there
who is considering
being a pastry chef,
what is the best
advice you could give them?
BILL CORBETT: I think you've
got to find your own path.
I don't think school is
necessarily a bad thing,
and I don't think working
your way up is a bad thing.
Sometimes it can be
really difficult also,
if you haven't gone to
school, to get somebody
to give you a chance.
So school is also
a way, I think,
for a lot of cooks to get
their foot in the door.
And I think it's important
for a lot of cooks.
I think it's really
difficult to not go to school
and take the path I took,
because no one wants
to give you the time of day.
So advice-wise, I would
just say keep trying.
Get involved with a chef
you're interested in,
but if you don't have any
of those basic skills,
like I worked in those
crappy restaurants coming up,
so I had this, I at
least had the language.
And I knew how to
hold a knife, and I
knew these very simple,
very basic skills.
But if you don't
have any of that,
if you're just like you're a
high school kid finishing up
school and you're
like I don't know
what I want to do with my life.
I like to cook, but
I've never really seen
what it's like inside a kitchen,
in a real professional kitchen.
I would advise either going
and learning what it's like
or going to school to get
the language so you can then
get your foot in the door.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
before I open it up
to questions from
all you guys, I
wanted to play a fun
little game with you
that I actually did
with Anthony Bourdain
a few years ago when
I interviewed him.
He loved it, by the way,
so I hope you will, too.
So I'm going to
say a topic, and I
want you to say the
first one or two
words that come into your
mind when you hear it.
So cake pops.
BILL CORBETT: Starbucks.
CAROLYN JUNG: Corona.
BILL CORBETT: Domenic Ansel.
CAROLYN JUNG: Pop
rocks in desserts.
BILL CORBETT: Lars
Ulrich from Metallica,
only because I made his
dad a birthday cake once
and put pop rocks in it.
CAROLYN JUNG: And
put pop rocks in it?
The Food Network's
Cupcake Wars show.
BILL CORBETT: A travesty,
I guess the first, yeah.
CAROLYN JUNG: Double
stuffed Oreos.
BILL CORBETT: Delicious.
CAROLYN JUNG: Butter.
BILL CORBETT:
Necessary, I guess.
CAROLYN JUNG: Ripe papaya.
BILL CORBETT: Vomit.
CAROLYN JUNG: That was
actually [INAUDIBLE]
because I know that's his
least favorite thing because
of the aroma of a ripe papaya.
Low-fat desserts.
BILL CORBETT: Eh, I guess.
CAROLYN JUNG: And last but
not least, Marissa Mayer's
fabled cupcake spreadsheet.
BILL CORBETT: I don't
know anything about that.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh, well, we
should connect them, right?
Well, thank you all, and
if you have any questions
we'd love to answer them.
You have any for Bill?
AUDIENCE: So my question is
you alluded to it a little bit.
You didn't grow up in a
foodie household or anything.
So I'm kind of curious.
What was your first
introduction to cooking?
Not like cooking in a
professional kitchen,
but just as a kid or
something, were you
flipping pancakes or something?
What did you do?
BILL CORBETT: I think for
me it was-- growing up,
food and cooking was
this total mystery to me,
and I was just like you
either knew how to do it,
or you didn't know how to do it.
And I didn't know how
to do it, so I was like,
I just never thought
I was going to cook.
I never would've expected to
end up cooking for a living,
but I think probably
the first time
I realized that you can actually
make something was probably
home EC class in seventh
grade or something like that.
And we made crepes, and
I didn't get an A, no.
I couldn't cook at that point.
I still was-- so I went home
and tried it again, though.
But it was this thing where I
was like oh, you can actually
make this.
This isn't something
you just buy,
or someone who knows
how to cook can make it.
You can actually make
something with the tools.
So that was my first
eye-opening experience.
It didn't really-- it
wasn't like oh, I'm
going to be a chef now.
Nothing like that, but it
was definitely my first.
That's the first time I remember
thinking oh, I can actually
cook something and apply heat to
something and change something
and make it actually
into something better
than the sum of its parts.
AUDIENCE: So
there's this delight
with pairing salty and sweet,
the caramel and sea salt thing.
Do you see that
continuing, or is
that where we're going, the
savory sweet intersection?
BILL CORBETT: I don't think it's
necessarily where we're going.
I think people are always
going to want dessert.
And I think it's
really important, also,
that when you're applying the
savory sweet set of things,
that you do it in a smart way
that suddenly isn't making
the product into an appetizer.
It's still going to be sweet.
It still has to
taste like dessert.
Most people want something
creamy and some maybe
crunchy texture involved,
maybe some cake.
So people are going to want
those textures, I think,
and people may go towards-- I
think the salty sweet thing has
its applications,
but I don't think
across the board
we're suddenly going
to be eating
everything salty sweet.
But I think it depends.
Caramel is better
with a little salt.
AUDIENCE: Does chocolate sell?
If you put a chocolate
dessert on your menu,
is it usually a top seller?
BILL CORBETT: Yeah, chocolate
is always a top seller.
I think people just
automatically go
for the chocolate dessert.
When people don't know what they
want, they just get chocolate,
I think.
Because chocolate does
things in your brain,
and that's why they gave it to
soldiers in the war and things
like that.
So yeah, I think chocolate
is always the big seller.
And honestly, it's the
hardest dish to make.
I think for me, the hardest
dishes are chocolate dishes.
Because I don't
think chocolate goes
with everything like
everybody pairs.
Chocolate has a way of being
paired with everything,
and I don't think it goes
with all these things
that people pair it with.
I don't think chocolate and
fruits are always the best.
Certain chocolates
and certain fruits.
It's treated like
a wine, almost,
where you're pairing terroir
and wherever the beans are grown
and how they're roasted,
and it changes everything.
It's like-- so
it's yeah, I think.
But definitely our number
one and two sellers
are chocolate desserts.
AUDIENCE: Have you
tried to incorporate
any international
cuisines into your style?
Because I know most
of the pastries,
like American, French, Italian
just within a few countries.
But have you tried anything
outside of the norm?
BILL CORBETT: I definitely
try to take inspiration,
I think, from new ingredients
that I might discover.
But I don't necessarily
try to copy a cuisine,
especially because I'm not fully
familiar with those cuisines
usually.
And if I try to copy,
it's going to come off
like this fake, non-authentic
version of what it should be.
So I'll take inspiration
maybe from a cuisine,
or I might use something
like a red curry paste
in a coconut ice cream.
But it's things like that, then
you get this coconut-curry ice
cream thing.
But I'm not going to try
to recreate, necessarily,
a Thai dish because I don't
understand the cuisine.
And I think it's going
to come off as phony.
AUDIENCE: Do you make
pastries at home,
or do you get friends and family
asking you to make things?
BILL CORBETT: I make stuff at
home sometimes, not very often.
And it's usually only for if I'm
going to a party or something,
then I'll make something.
But generally I don't
make pastry at all.
I usually just cook
savory at home.
But yeah, I don't
cook a lot of pastry.
I think it drives me crazy
because I have this-- at work,
I have this amazing
kitchen with all the tools,
and there's this is
non-exhaustible supply of pots
because the dishwasher
will wash them.
And when I'm at home,
it's this tiny space,
I have some of the equipment,
but not all the equipment.
And I don't have
the convection oven.
And it's kind of an
excuse, to be honest.
But it's like, but it's
like, it's just not as fun.
And so I'm kind of stuck working
with tools that I necessarily
like working with,
and it's not--
it just doesn't come as
easily, so I'd rather just
do it at work and
then bring it home.
AUDIENCE: Did you make
your own wedding cake?
BILL CORBETT: No,
my mother-in-law
made my wedding cake.
Actually, it was before I worked
in pastry that I got married.
So I hadn't-- I was not good
at making pastry at that point.
But my mother-in-law for
years, not when we got
married, but years before,
had a cake business.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh, interesting.
BILL CORBETT: So
she would always
make all these crazy
cakes, like all the ones
in different shapes,
really amazing.
She's an amazing
cake decorators.
She does stuff that's
not in my wheelhouse.
CAROLYN JUNG: Wow,
that's high praise.
BILL CORBETT: So she did,
yeah, she did our wedding cake,
and we actually got
married in their backyard,
in my in-laws' back yard.
They live on a lake in Tampa.
It poured rain in the morning.
It was a great time.
It actually all turned out
OK, but it was stressful.
OLIVIA: Chef, will you
talk about the dessert
and all the components of it?
Let me get it for you.
BILL CORBETT: So we have
two desserts for you to try,
and one is the one
we did in the class
we did a little earlier, which
was we did a milk chocolate
cream of basil meringue
and a hazelnut crumb.
OLIVIA: It was good.
BILL CORBETT: And
then this one here
is actually the beet
cake that's in the book.
So it's beet cake with fromage
blanc frosting and candied
walnuts And we garnished
it with a little bit
of beet paper and
beet caramel sauce.
OLIVIA: How do you
make beet paper?
BILL CORBETT: So it's
actually really simple.
It looks like--
people probably think
it's some scientific thing, and
we use some crazy weird gums
to make it happen, but all
we do is we take beet puree.
We roast the beets, puree them.
We add a little bit
of sugar, and then we
spread it really thin
and dehydrate it.
OLIVIA: It's just so
stunning to look at.
CAROLYN JUNG: I just want
to add one thing, which
is for some people,
this cake might
be a little of a
stretch to make.
It's a little-- it's
not hard or complicated,
but it does take a little bit
of time, and it's incredible.
But I would like to put a
plug in for the garnish that
is actually not on there today.
The walnut ice cream,
which you've heard me
rave about this.
So I actually made
the ice cream when
I was testing recipes
for this book,
and if you have an ice
cream maker, it's so simple.
And I tell you, it is
the best walnut ice
cream I have ever had.
I was spinning it in the
machine and keeping--
I couldn't stop putting my spoon
into the hole to grab tastes.
I mean, I'm shocked
there was any left
to actually freeze
in the freezer.
That's how good it is.
So if you want to make
something of Bill's in the book,
that is a little bit simpler.
I recommend, though,
walnut ice cream for sure.
Well, thank you all
so much, and we're
going to be here signing copies
of the book, San Francisco
Chefs Table, also
hope you'll come by,
and we'll be happy to
personalize them to you.
Thank you.